[Musique]
bon ça revient oui je vous demandais
s'ils allaient s'en vient ça va revenir
faire un tour aujourd'hui qu'hier
à suivre oui
[Musique]
alors bon soir à la planète tous bonjour
au canada bienvenue à tandem canada en
direct de montréal en compagnie de mes
collègues de la section française de
radio-canada international spot studio
on va bientôt apparaître en couleur
voici donc de droite à gauche et de
gauche à droite
voici à l'isq est avec nous ismaël
bonjour stéphane d'accord on a quelques
minutes de retard aujourd'hui c'est
parce que bon on avait à la grogne des
grosses têtes un peu chargé puis ça
prend du temps de nous rendre du de
notre bureau à notre studio est tout de
même 1 km qui nous séparent des deux est
farceur dénonce une farce
et puis non dans le temps parce qu'on
avait des détails des techniques à à
corriger mais là on est en santé on est
là à écouter on est prêt pour vous
montrer notre vidéo 5 images depuis nos
collègues anciens studios vont tenter de
déterminer grâce à ces images d'eux
aussi le sujet de notre émission
aujourd'hui on regarde ça ensemble
d'aller voir un jour vous allez me dire
de quoi on parle aujourd'hui
ne soyez pas trop rapide en 1 vers ces
ensembles coronavirus jeu sur une bonne
piste après mois les épidémies c'est sûr
qu'on va parler de ça mais encore on
recherche le vaccin oui on va
certainement est à la recherche sur la
piste de choses semblables mais encore
vous êtes en train de sécher à l'examen
wizo les bonnes réponses
le temps clément grand de laboratoire
canadien et du laboratoire national de
microbiologie contre le chrono virus
d'accord où je dis moi j'aurais dit que
renault avait reçu de la part des
français renault on est atterri à cuba
écoutez alors ça c'est notre sujet
aujourd'hui aux intérêts des
laboratoires de type 4 de type 3
d'accord j'ai juste un véritable
casse-tête un point les scientifiques
eux c'est ça trouver un vaccin c'est pas
du tout donné on disait quelqu'un
atteint pouvais faire c'était l'opinion
exprimée par un responsable canadien ça
pour apprendre l on sait que dans le cas
de certains de ces cônes au corona
coronavirus comme celui de 2012 au moyen
orient n'a toujours pas de vaccin
d'accord on est chanceux parce qu a pas
de victime
cette maladie a fait son chemin comme ça
fait pas enterré dans le désert
d'accord mais là c'est pas sur ce qui va
se passer on va regarder la situation
avec un spécialiste le voici le voilà
sur skype
il s'agit d'un grave chercheurs
canadiens dr guy boivin
microbiologiste-infectiologue au centre
universitaire hospitalier de québec
et puis il est bon d'avoir accepté notre
invitation cette semaine vous êtes très
occupé et c'est pas parce qu'il se passe
quelque chose mondialement que vous êtes
nécessairement très occupés sais pas ce
qui s'est passé la semaine dernière un
événement important pour le québec dans
l'ensemble de quoi il s'agit cette année
c'est fait au beau milieu des rations et
des banques firmes à minettes docteur
olivier on va tenter de vous appeler au
téléphone puisque la communication skype
est vraiment enrhumé aujourd'hui et a
fait la connaissance des nazis mouvement
donc on vous appelle au téléphone ça va
prendre deux trois minutes pour rétablir
la communication tout à fait et pendant
ce temps je vais vous proposer de
regarder ceux ci c'est la deuxième
question de la grosse boule ça fait
c'est notre première question
aujourd'hui à la grosse foule alors
premier tour il ya trois jeux par
édition il ya 20 boules à perdre pour le
premier jeu vous allez voir c'est qu'on
vous donne ses points ses premiers
points pour la première question
on n'affiche pas à l'écran en 2003
souvenez vous on parlait beaucoup du
strass c'est à dire le syndrome
respiratoire aigu sévère comme si ce
n'était pas assez grave
alors ça on appelle ça le strass et en
2003 si la question dans quel animal le
corona virus responsable de l'épidémie
du strass aurait-il alors pris naissance
à ce moment là vous avez un choix ici
deux réponses possibles
est ce que c'est le sens à l'aise une
espèce de grippe aviaire
je voulais c'est le collège sans parler
du climat qui est fait dans vous misez
son p le poulet le poulet moi j'aime
beaucoup le poulet aussi c'est unanime
j'ai mon serment le serpent j'aime pas
tellement voici on va regarder comment
vous monte et ça descend de s'ennuyer
donc donner tous est surpris voici nos
cinq étoiles vont s'afficher voilà au
carré pas aucune alors qu'est ce que ce
serait si c'est pas le poulet le singe
ou le sanglier l'origine du strass du
coup on arriverait à ce moment là
c'était d'origine animale mais de quel
animal
ah oui j'en souris mâles est l'intérieur
monfils m'en parler de nous
mais maman à l'école tu sais tout le
monde dit là bas c'est parce qu'en chine
les gens ont dû peut-être côtoyer des
chauves souris
les tâches sont bien des fois ils
peuvent nous instruire 16 ans oui ils en
savent plus que nous partions paraît
grande chose sourit sont remplies de
bactéries et de virus sur tout et russes
mais qu'ils ont un système qui à toute
épreuve qui pourrait permettre s'ils
sont enceintes et de combattre à peu
près tous plus que nous et dans ce cas
là il nous avait transmis la maladie et
on pense je lisais ce matin que le corps
et le virus
présentement en chine viendrait
également d'une source chauve souris
c'est pour confirmer la saison on
discute en ce moment mais on en a parlé
comme ça avec gollum et maman c'est
vraiment une chauve souris
j'étais comme maintenant ça s'est bien
passé comme un défaut ce garçon là il ya
des gens qui disaient à des projets avec
les chauves souris au canada attention
ils vont nous communiquer des villes ça
va être encore plus grave attaque ce qui
se passe en chine
tout à fait c'est vraiment apprendre la
machine à rumeurs parfois aussi faire
attention mais c'est la consommation
d'eau chaude sous ben écoutez il y avait
je sais pas s'ils consomment des chauves
souris
mais il ya peut-être eu cohabitation
entre une chauve-souris s'appuie un
poulet d'être en contact mais un peu
trop d'accord je sais pas si marcher sur
souris certains coins je le ferai
écoutez son nom mais un stop à la grosse
boule on va aller voir si notre
spécialiste du laboratoire deux-tiers de
niveau 3 à québec est avec nous au
téléphone bonjour professeur docteur à
il dépasse d'accord moi je le vois la
caméra mais aussi je le vois mais nous
oui c'est puissant des groupes à bombay
en attendant on vous entend peut-être
mais nous on n'entend pas et nous prêts
pour la suite des événements deuxième
question vous avez fait pas j'en ai des
questions
mission vous avez des questions on y va
avec le deuxième tour de la grosse boule
train bull à perdre
ça va être amusant voir si vous avez
bien regardé à la télévision bien lu
dans les journaux cette semaine ce qui
se passe quel est le nom utilisé par les
scientifiques pour désigner en ce moment
le coronavirus ce dont on parle tant
est-ce que c'est à 20,19
c'est au v n os que c b le 20 19
nc au v ou est ce que c'est c'est le vin
19/n cvo c'est aux veines ou est ce que
c'est des cons virus muté le dd oui
d'accord avec les bleus devaient sauver
le d'entre vous à conserver ces points
on sait d'après vous séisme a affiché la
veille
c'est quelque chose que moi j'ai vu tout
au long de la semaine les quinze jours
j'ai dit mais c'est vrai mais c'est vrai
c'est le nom officiel aura pas de
discussion possible ici à l'émission
voilà alors si on n'est pas prêt pour le
professeur docteur guy olivier ihl mais
j'aurai une autre question mais je vais
me tourner vers la régie qui bien sûr
elle qui la seule qui pilote cette
émission de façon logique alors la régie
dites moi sommes nous prêts à part le
docteur aux spécialistes
ça sera pas long on y va avec la
troisième question prévue à l'émission
aujourd'hui on déboule la grosse boule
50 points conservez d'accord ismaël sy
là vous avez tous vos points mais en
attendant on peut faire le point sur le
corona on est rendu à combien de morts
combien de cas en chine plus de 9700
aujourd'hui puis à 5 jours c'était 2700
j'ai vérifié je me suis dit à quelle
vitesse a évolué c'est chou
mais pourquoi est-ce qu'il ya encore au
canada 3 confiant mais confirmé way
confirmé qu'un certain nombre de
personnes qui sont en observation
ok donc c'est le cas qui était un
handicap en observation ok mais son nom
de personnes en observation il ya aussi
la situation dans les aéroports
canadiens plus de mesures draconiennes
aux etats unis quand j'ai des regrets
nous c'est vers un petit peu mot canada
puis la critique commencent à lever
on se dit voit arriver des passagers car
et asie ah oui justement
et est-ce qu'on en est avec le
rapatriement des canadiens qui se
trouvent c'est connu leur fils pour le
moment par des problèmes de pas de
tracasseries mais une bureaucratie entre
les deux pays le canada
notre invité est la dr guy boivin merci
d'être resté avec nous et d'être au
téléphone alors votre grands
laboratoires de niveau iii a ouvert le
24 derniers s'étaient donc il ya
exactement une semaine
c'est une drôle de coïncidence
est ce que vous êtes des gens après de
travailler vous êtes déjà comme ils
disent les anglais hope for business
vous êtes déjà sur le cas le plus
important pour pour bien traiter et de
ne pas la manquer
quand vous êtes un test génétique c'est
quelque chose que vous pourriez nous
administrer en l'espace d'une heure ou
deux on sait que on a dit dos tout c'est
un peu plus long que ça
ce que vous envisagez on parle de une
couple d'heures peut-être de biologie
moléculaire donc on détecte le code
génétique des virus dont celui des
niveaux convenables chrono virus
provenant de chine
on le compare où aucun navire aux graves
sont cons à vireux du moyen-orient et au
tour sur un virus plus bénin mais
important que les tracteurs antiques
franco ennuyeuse parce que dès qu'on ne
les redonne des rhumes
c'est un fait banal
pas de mortalité y en a d'autres comme
le flash le corno virus du moyen-orient
qui ont des taux de mortalité de 60 5%
celui qui nous intéresse à la rectrice
de lui provient de chine
on parle le totalité avec les données
qui ne sont pas parvenus de la chine on
parle d'un taux de mortalité d'environ 1
1 2 point saint marc ont été reproduits
quand même un très rapidement dans ce
que vous voilà on va montrer des images
de la journée de vendredi dernier alors
que on ouvrez votre laboratoire au grand
public
quand je dis au louvre grand public ça
durera pas longtemps je souhaite vous
avez désinfecter les lieux depuis mais
écouter sérieusement dans ce que vous
observez est ce que dans les
échantillons du virus que vous avez en
main est ce qu'on observe des dépôts le
virus est pas toujours le même il ya des
différences ils évoluent est ce que vous
avez des informations à ce sujet la wii
bonne question
même les icônes au virus qu'on appelle
2009 trouvé ton portrait d'eric jeux
d'imitation entre les différents virus
provient de pain
on ne peut pas encore les auteurs entre
les mains du jeu proviennent d'autres
pays mais par contre la séquence
génétique de plusieurs iphone et sur le
web
donc on peut faire des alignements
comparer et en comparant ces fréquences
la dignité qu'on s'aperçoit
qu'effectivement oui des mutations est
ce que ça veut dire que ces virus qui
ont muté là sont des détections fuiter
vers le phare est la voie là pendant
qu'on regarde ces images ou vous
adresser aux médias vendredi dernier on
va faire une transition vers winnipeg le
laboratoire national ou qui est de
niveau 4 le vôtre est de niveau 3
j'aimerais que il en va voir des images
tournées par cible ici cette semaine
c'est quand même quelque chose qu'on est
puissant de qu'on ait pu être invité là
c'est vraiment le cid ici donc le center
for this can choix aux canadiens etc
il ya des différences entre votre
laboratoire et celui là fait vous ne
donniez une image de ce que c'est c'est
ce que ça représente le lot jong un
niveau 3 au niveau 4
qui travaillent avec des micro
organismes d'aidé sur des bactéries des
virus des champignons du gaz dont
classée de niveau 1 niveau 4 cela qui le
classera des pathogènes nous limiterons
organes et le départ de plusieurs
critères parmi ces critères l'oeil le
fait que le la bactérie où le virus est
dangereux pour lui même est ce que il
existe des traitements des vaccins en
cas d'accident ce qu'il a pensé de ces
micro-organismes acheminés dans la
collectivité
parce qu'en fait rapidement entre
humains alors sur ces critères là où il
se rend pas d'agenda et éclaircies de
niveau en niveau 4 niveaux trop comme le
nôtre on peut tolérer des virus comme
les usa grippe aviaire le fameux à
championnat qu'on ne parlait durant
plusieurs années
on peut travailler aussi avec des corps
le virus se soit les traces de villes de
chine celui du moyen-orient on peut
parier avec ce qu'on appelle des
arbovirus transmis par des moustiques
comme le virus de la dengue une fièvre
jaune est ce qu'on peut pour faire je ne
peux pas travailler avec lui aussi cosy
fiel virale hémorragique
comme le virus et boules socialement
d'un niveau de confinement 4 il ne
seulement un laboratoire au niveau de
confinement 4 au kendo et celui de
winnipeg comme de les mentionner
il a besoin national du produit dont la
vocation est principalement la
surveillance du diagnostic
nous ne vaut qu'à son premier affirmant
au niveau de la recherche qui va qui
vont inventer le vaccin c'est que
j'allais poser ils se foutent de faire
c'est ce qu'on est en bonne voie de
découvrir un vaccin pour stopper ce
virus là notre expérience montre que
c'est trop pour effet de développer des
vaccins
la preuve c'est qu'on n'a pas développé
de la cré contre le trac circuler en
2002 2003 mais comme vous l'avez
mentionné le canot virus moyens d'ariane
2012 c'est une des raisons pour laquelle
de la difficulté du stup reste est
importé mais qui amène un niveau de
difficulté plus élevé c'est que ce virus
que qu'on qualifie ainsi pour qui
possède deux chromosomes un arn fonds de
mutation est plus fréquent que des virus
possède un chromosome contient de l'adn
je m'explique il est russe considère en
effet le virus vih l'hépatite b et les
cours ne vise qu'à mettre constamment
beaucoup plus fréquemment des virus tu
possèdes l'adn comme les vieux serpents
flies l'on distingue plus que plus
fréquemment avec le cpie de développer
un vaccin contre tu vois qu'il aurait
compté des entrevues doivent ramener la
production d'articles comme toutes les
filles ont muté est ce que dans la
recherche est toujours important de
connaître le patient zéro le segment d
épidémie de virus c'est quelque chose
qui peut être important pour découvrir
des vaccins est ce que ça l'est là dans
ce cas-ci découvrir comment le virus a
sauté la barrière des effets le
réservoir probablement une chauve souris
mais la plupart des humains ou ont pas
été affectée par la chauve souris à one
il ya probablement un animal entre les
deux attachées aux souris il humain qui
a transmis le virus à dublin dans le
coup de grâce en 2003 cet animal
internet vers le c'était l'acte iv mais
me farama jurés et dont les chinois
raffolent pour comme nourriture qui
était qui étaient incriminés dans le
code les ducs ont avivé du moyen-orient
2012 l'état menzah c'était le dromadaire
donc qui était le réservoir qui ce prix
qui est effectué par une chauve souris
infectées par la suite l'homme bon ça
c'est un diamètre est connu de la source
il faut aussi s'organiser pour qu il ait
pas de réintroduction de cette source de
cette source d oslo
chez l'humain
vous y avait des problèmes qu'on a avec
la lâcher manoel leur fameux marché
d'animaux vivants où les contacts entre
l'homme et l'animal
donc comment le plus élevé que ce qu'on
voit dans les pays d'amérique du nord ou
en europe et d'octobre avant j'aurais
une question je sais pas si on peut se
permettre cette comparaison là on sait
que le monde entier est en alerte par
rapport aux coronavirus je veux savoir
s'il faut comparer par rapport au nombre
de morts qu'est ce qui serait plus
mortelle entre le virus qui cause la
grippe qu'on a les épisodes qu'on a
souvent ici chez nous en amérique du
nord et le coronavirus qu'est ce qui
serait plus mortelle c'est votre selon c
est une bonne question que vaut il faut
toujours aller plus les corps de rire
les provenant de chine maintenant amener
le décès de deux centrales de personnes
matin chaque année la grippe cause de
trois à cinq mille dt au canada donc on
est loin du compte avec le coup de vieux
les premiers chiffres ne parlent que des
faits à l'extérieur de la chine y en a 2
1 202 203 en chine
donc c'est beaucoup plus dangereux to
view beaucoup de chance que personne
n'essaie de la grèce at il dit à la
chaîne
parce que j'ai appris que le canada
était le seul pays hors de la chine
avoir eu des décès lors de l'épisode du
strass aucun autre pays avait eu des
décès à hormis la chine donc le canada
et c'est une c'est un lieu
106 ch part-dieu pas eu qu'à lentement
44 quelque chose est détectée est
infecté et environ 40 frère de mémoire
me veut c'est exact on a pris par contre
depuis le crime y trace de métro on
s'est créé qu'une version on est capable
d'éradiquer la transition si on emploie
des mesures de santé publique qui sont
très strict alors ces virus se
transmette ne sont les contacts étroits
conduits par contact étroit c'est
surtout les contacts familiaux ou les
contacts produit quand une personne est
hospitalisée et que les mesures de faire
du public ne sont pas bien activée on ne
propose pas de matelas blues la visière
de 0,6 en un an 3 on isole rapidement
les corps en tracé contact on isole ses
contacts
on va venir un bon je suis certain de ce
type de contenu à bout depuis 2003 2004
depuis que chez l'humain peut-être que
le réservoir animal est encore présent
et quand une réintroduction un jour pour
l'instant on a réussi à contenir cette
petit minot donc je pense que le lot de
problèmes avec le nouveau core 2 duo et
si tu arrives dans un pays dont les
infrastructures sanitaires sont moins
bonnes par exemple en afrique certains
pays d'asie où ça pourrait toutefois
créer pas mal de dommages mais je pense
pas qu'un pays comme le canada les
etats-unis où la plupart des pays
européens
on voit de gros problèmes avec alice oui
au fait
dr boivin il ya des canadiens qui sont
en ce moment coincé en chine qui vont
bientôt être rapatriés ici c'est sûr que
dans les aéroports on a des protocoles
qui sont en place même dans les hôpitaux
aussi le directeur de la santé publique
du québec l'a dit ces derniers jours
si vous aviez des conseils à prodiguer à
l'endroit de la population ici que leur
diriez vous pour s'en prémunir
[Musique]
le seul danger potentiel pour
l'installer et un canadien serein dans
la province de la ville de wuhan
il ya quand même un risque mais pour
l'instant il réunit 48 ans va être
sympathique de cette province chinoise
donc les risques sont minimes
pour l'instant je ne pense pas que du de
s'alarmer comme le dos et à la santé
publique du québec a mentionné hier et
tout ce qu'on connaît la date de ce
n'était pas ainsi que les pouilles virus
qui particulièrement dangereux
bien entendu car c'est quelque chose
qu'on connaît mal son connais pas
tellement ça met toujours plus de
crainte que des risques connus qu'on
voit chaque année
oui mais parlons des mesures de sécurité
dans les aéroports il ya des différences
entre pays présentement notamment entre
les etats-unis le canada
on a tenté des expériences lors de
l'épidémie du strass auque au canada
pour contrôler les passagers qui
arrivaient qui était plus sévère
on a dépensé ou d'autres 7 millions de
dollars et on a répertorié aucun aucun
passager malade mais dans ce cas ci est
ce que les soyons raison s'inquiéter du
retour au pays par exemple de canadiens
qui se trouverait en chine pays ont pris
des mesures
quand un rapatriement de la population
on compare la france l'australie les
états-unis canada que j'ai entendu pour
la part des autorités canadiennes lui
qui aurait pas de quarantaine au retour
des îles ressortent pas canal de lachine
dois avouer qu'il est sain plus
surprenant on ne s'attendait à voir une
quarantaine au moins de sept à dix jours
parce que les premières données qu'on a
les autorités chinoises parlent d'une
période d'incubation le 5 jours mais
avec un étendue que parler de 2,2 trois
jours jusqu'à 7 à 10 jours la période
d'expiration ces deux modes la période
entre le moment qu'on est infecté il me
manque développent des symptômes donc
qui veut dire quelqu'un qui arriverait
aujourd'hui au canada partagent à eux
il reconnaît seulement les cinq tons
très pas décemment isolé et pourrait
développer les symptômes quelques jours
plus tard donc moi je me serais
personnellement attendu à ce que des
mesures de quarantaine
appliquée pour les ressources 5 qui
revient de chine et dans ce cas là
qu'est ce que la population canadienne
du pressoir pour se mettre à l'abri de
ce virus là parce que je comprends c'est
que même et rien pas de mesures de
quarantaine en voirie suivi étroit
alors je pense que de toute façon il n'y
a pas de raison de s'inquiéter
le poids de foyers actifs de
multiplication du virus au canada en ce
moment pas encore une chose doit être
surveillé par exemple des foyers de
réplication de vivre à l'extérieur de la
chine a fait il ya quatre ou cinq pays
qui rapporte les échos qui ont été
contractées en dehors de la chine
et c'est important mais ici c'est
certain pour plusieurs générations de
copulation en général contenu à
l'extérieur de la chine en même temps
c'est assez étonnant parce que bon en
chine
est ce que on fait un peu la
géopolitique là mais ils ont rien appris
du strass c'est quand même un pays qui
surveille sa population à un niveau
assez inédit comment une épidémie puisse
éclore aussi rapidement et avec des
chiffres aussi énorme dans un pays ultra
surveillé et en plus qui a déjà connu
des épisodes de colloques coronavirus
est important il a évolué et on compare
un 2003 et 2009 2020 avec ici c'est
aller beaucoup plus vite la divulgation
des hélicos de partage des faits car le
virus on parle de premiers cas sont
apparus en chine de pneumonie due à un
agent indéterminée à ce moment là à la
mi décembre
on ne fait le lien assez rapidement dans
quelques jours quelques semaines qu'elle
est de plus passé qu'on leur connaît
d'un contact avec un marché de poissons
et d'animaux ce marché-là été fermé dès
le 1er janvier élevé giorgio
d'identifier l'agent causal de type
mondo peut être encore nos vieux le 12
janvier des séquences du nouveau camp de
virus étaient partagés avec loi m donc
on réagit frattini maintenant le
problème encore une fois si les fameux
marché de volailles plus d'animaux sont
ouverts au grand public à l'air libre
qui amènent des contacts potentiels des
virus chez les ch et l'animal chez
loiseau et il est humain qui fréquentent
le mari le docteur boivin va falloir se
quitter là dessus ce fut extrêmement
nourris sein de vous écouter la à la
fois un peu plus inquiète un peu plus
rassurés en voyant ça au moins quoi
surveiller je pense que c'est important
vous nous avez donné des pistes à
surveiller merci beaucoup docteur merci
prochain adapteur guy boivin
microbiologiste et infectiologue au
centre hospitalier universitaire de
québec
c'est quelqu'un qui connaît le monde
partout au canada qui a reçu des des
prix honorifiques c'est vraiment
quelqu'un très éclairant rouaix écoutez
on est prêt pour le troisième tour de
notre trousse bull et la réponse a été
donnée en entrevue mais de façon
partielle se bat pas docteur boivin
d'accord alors voici troisième on a fait
chez la question 50 boules à perdre je
voulais savoir combien vous en avez là
sur cinq ans je sais plus moi je pense
que j'en ai 30 me garder on a passé on
n'a pas lu la question ça ok ça sera pas
l'ordre de régine chance de remonter la
pente
le strass avait fait 5900 victimes en
chine premier pays où il y avait une
fois de plus de problème le deuxième
pays c'était hong kong avec 1650 quatre
victimes sont pas des gens qui sont
vraiment des gens qui ont été infectés
le canada était troisième sur la liste
des pays les plus touchés par le strass
incroyable mais vrai combien de
personnes avaient été infectées au
canada
est-ce que c'est à 1025 est ce que c b
521 au terme d'une année de
contamination est-ce que c'est ces 251
ou est-ce que c'était 125 il y avait eu
44 morts je le précise donc ça vous
donne peut-être un ordre de grandeur ici
quelle est la bonne réponse comme une
personne dont canada avait infecté
surtout dans les jantes ont tous alors
ouais ça se comprend on a beaucoup
d'asiatiques quinivet sur la côte ouest
canadienne
puis à toronto si attentes aussi il a b
c ou d
on a besoin de réponses b&b 521 faites
vos jeux rien ne va plus la bonne
réponse on affiche les 5 étoiles avec
impatience un gardien personnes décédées
c'est tout
de 17 magasins seulement voilà et c'est
sérieux ce jour aura goûté au plaisir de
vous avoir ici un fusio pour répondre
aux différentes questions et pour poser
des questions à nous partager way fait
et puis aujourd'hui ne fait pas
exception même si on parle ce qui est
assez il faut en parler l'âge et je
voulais vous faire sourire je pense
j'espère c'est notre image de la semaine
vous devez deviner et je réponds
seulement par oui ou par non quelle est
cette image
j'attends vos questions quelle est
l'image de la semaine selon vous l'image
de la semaine n'ont pas trouvé l'image
de la semaine
[Musique]
non ça c'est la synthèse de retrouver le
cette semaine en tout cas les
toulonnaises poteau genève tous les
mentonnais je n'ai pas tous les
mentonnais non serment mieux encore ils
sont généralement cachés sous l'eau
d'accord c'est pas la bonne réponse
est-ce que c'est aux états unis ce
procès aux états unis
est ce que c'est le président non ils
n'ont pas ce que nous on en a assez le
non non non non non non non non c'est
pas les élections américaines
non non enfin la campagne pas du tout
pas du tout ça n'a rien à voir avec les
élections ça à voir avec quand même
c'est pas la météo c'est pas la science
est un de ces grands sujets ce dossier
qui est médiatisé souvent ah non je
pensais aux couples non je ne sais pas
un procès non non c'est arrivé dimanche
ouais mais dimanche aux environs de 3h
et 3h30
moi je suis pour le sport mais quand
j'ai entendu le nom jyske toutefois
cette personnalité c'est très très très
bon très très grand soin de masquer est
bonne voie alors l'un des plus aisément
avec sa fille de 13 ans est un
journaliste qui dit qu'il était mort
avec les quatre enfants qui l'avaient
non non non non non c'est pas c'est fait
avec sa fille une amie de sa fille des
parents de cet ami l'a et combien ils
étaient 39 9 mai lors de ce qui est elle
ou avait annoncé le décès le tabloïd
oui avant que la famille soit en cours
avant que la police informée moi je les
presse que suivi en direct - dont
j'accompagnais mon fils un saison à ces
pratiques de basketball et donc
l'entraîneur vers 3h30 nous dit bah
écoutez écoutez yacoub et mauvaises
nouvelles on lui demande qu'est ce qui
se passe il dit kobe bryant tous les
enfants étaient combien nombreux
c'est injuste oui très très connue des
jeunes est un sportif très engagé auprès
des gens engagés auprès des jeunes très
très prolifique durant sa carrière parce
qu'il a marqué plus de 33000 points ah
oui en 3000 panier et il était le
troisième meilleur
comment dire ça c'est buteur ou quoi au
basket ball on parle de quoi marqueurs
de l'histoire du basket dans une icône
et il se trouve que la veille de son
décès lebron james à l'abattre certains
à voir là se positionnant à la dure à la
deuxième position au 2e rang juste après
taille et un autre à m'ennuie vite
oublié le nom
est-ce que ça maintenant non c'est pas
mal non pas moi votre fiston il ay
d'aussi grave et gras où il est il est
assis l'ipam altran pour son âge mais
bon il aime le basket
ouais bah oui donc ça ne veut toucher
énormément énormément
ben voilà c'est tout pour cette semaine
merci beaucoup d'un merci d'avoir été là
avec nous également cette semaine ou la
semaine prochaine ses fans à la semaine
prochaine dans votre cas est allé sur
votre congé qui va rentrer
[Musique]